uh we have another update from that
coffee City police force
another one another one God yeah dude
another one this is great
we are demanding answers after a series
of ma'am
are you pregnant
a linebacker the investigations revealed
Miss Cox Brian Urlacher in a wig
we're hearing
from the mayor of the city good evening
I'm Martin Lopez over the course of last
week we brought you multiple stories
outlining shortcomings in the hiring
practices of coffee City police and the
police chief's own history of legal
trouble Brennan Gurley is here with us
with the latest chapter of this
investigation a story that you'll only
see here on CBS 19. I'm realizing that
these sneakers didn't match my suit well
my wife assured me they would look great
laughs
bring it what Brandon what did you hear
from the mayor today hey Mara good
evening the mayor wants to move past
this ugly check guy guy I'm sorry now I
want to zoomed in even more you know you
don't just buy those suits off the rack
and put them on you get them tailored
you know that right like you see how
loose look at the bottom look at his
hands on the feet too look it's really
bad like it's a badly tailored tune
wants to move past this ugly chapter for
coffee City and he said he looks like in
mid-transition when Tom Hanks was
turning back into a kid in big and he's
walking away like in the middle right in
the middle yeah
as he supports it thorough did you visit
a zoltar machine recently
right around that time that that chick
realized she molested a child yeah Tom
Hanks likes big because he got to play
the thing he wants to [__] litigation
into the police department
and after the allegations about our
police chief and our warrant division
came out then we were kind of like oh
now we're going to have to do something
a city investigating one of its own
following the suspension of its police
chief and the suspension of an entire
division of the police department mayor
Jeff Blackstone says he's dedicated to
getting answers our plan right now is
just to get to the bottom of this figure
out where things are going to go from
there and then that's the mayor that's
the guy that was actually allowing all
this [__] to happen and he's now
throwing that Chief under the bus you're
the mayor you couldn't put a suit on
your ring a Patagonia shirt it's coffee
City dude that's right building
Blackstone and other city council
members have ordered an independent
investigation Chief John Jay Portillo is
serving a 30-day suspension an
investigation buyer sister stationed in
Houston uncovered that Portillo failed
to disclose an active DWI charge out of
Florida on his job application to be
coffee City's police chief in 2021. I
don't think that works in law
enforcement if I'm I may not be correct
I don't know and it's not you're the
mayor
just the chief according to Personnel
records more than half of the coffee
City officers had been suspended demoted
or dishonorably discharged from their
previous jobs I was not pleased whenever
I heard the alligator he was the mayor
wasn't pleased guys because the mayor
definitely wasn't in on it or true then
that's shorts hold on yeah bro it's
coffee City the mayor of coffee City
lives in a [__] prefab home where he
has a casual Friday okay
Homer it's Wednesday
that looks weird no that prefab home is
probably the mayor's office you're right
that's a really it's a it's a [__]
portable
yeah series of reports also rebuild
coffee City hauled in a million dollars
in court no that's not the oh my God
that's the city hall
yeah the mayor what mayor's office
that's all of city oh my God yeah man
it's a little [__] no no-name Town
last year which can be really good or
really bad depending on who the sheriffs
are yes and has the police in this case
not great this is a bad one but there's
a small one just like two people and
like the they'll be they'll be the
sheriff said if you're drunk if it's
small town they just throw your keys in
the grass and go pick it up tomorrow go
Uber home yeah
he's forces of 50 officers five times
the number of officers in any other
Texas town its size mayor Blackstone
says and you guys really love that
effect huh they just really gonna milk
that huh just got Final Cut Pro leave
him alone
shake the reputation the city has for
being a speed trap if you look at our
ratio of tickets to
um uh warnings
warnings are almost double the amount as
taken well that's good
that just means you still pull a lot of
people over we're really trying tickets
though to get people to slow down but
how many of those warnings start with
hey Jim yeah you're right
to not you know monetize that we asked
Tamir Blackstone how many officers are
currently employed through the city I
don't really know the correct answer to
that we've it's your job
it's and it's not even like he's the
mayor of Houston no or something like a
major city it's like you got a couple
things you got to keep up on there's 250
people that you should know every one of
them on a first name basis yeah you know
honestly I've actually put in a request
to get an updated roster we have not yo
these Sunny divock assault is [__]
lit getting that information well an
independent investigation is underway
Lieutenant Lonnie Hicks is the officer
in charge of the coffee City Police
Department mayor blacks don't say who's
just a little less corrupt than Portillo
has he and other city leaders will hold
a high standard for them I'm sorry I've
watched too many Scorsese movies you
don't trust a guy named Lonnie no you
don't you're of the police department
good for us to have a police department
that but we need to have a good Police
Department you don't need one you need
five people you know you know what I'm
gonna you get 250 you get 10 cops in
that town five that works how about no
cops just you have a sheriff's
department 250 people it should be you
know unincorporated part of the county
hey tell me how many cops Key West has
apartment
this afternoon the Texas commission I am
shrinking on law enforcement or t Cole
confirmed it's investigating the coffee
City Police Department it's a state
agency that regulates all peace officers
in Texas the coffee City councils will
good news merch you go watch CBS 19 if
you download their exclusive Roku app
ew I know
CBS is in trouble huh yeah it is it's
meeting Monday at 6 p.m it is open to
the public we will be there and bring
you any new information on air and
online at
cbs19.tv oh man you are a huge [__]
Brennan thank you
those sleeves are stretched the [__] out
oh sorry I was muted I'm looking at Key
West right now um I found it was hard to
find but I found out some website uh
apparently there's about 344 departments
uh Key West I don't know I'm trying to
get a number I mean I I guarantee you
they have less cops than coffee City
doesn't Key West has a lot of drunks